dinner rolls are actually a super sexy
super satisfying and honestly like one
of the better parts of a big
banquet meal it's a very easy
introduction to dough an introduction to
bread but dinner roll is basically like
your fourth utensil right so you have
your fork your knife your spoon
and then you have your dinner roll and
that's what's going to help sop up all
like the really best parts of your
dinner
so respect it
there's a bunch of different types of
flour out there you've got the whole
wheat that has the bran
in there you've got almond flour all
these different gluten-free options
nowadays
we're going to use all-purpose when
you're starting out making bread
all-purpose is a great one to start with
because it is so refined it's very
predictable it's going to give you the
result that you're after
yeast so there's like three standard
ones you can get in the u.s
and around the world they're called
different things in different places you
have active dry
you have instant nice and you also have
fresh here we have all the different
tests for yeast to see
what would the result be in the bread
could we really taste or see a
difference in the rising in terms of
speed
how big the dough's got all of that so
we bloomed the fresh and the active dry
we did not bloom to wrap it because it
is not recommended to do so
we all use the exact same amount of
ingredients we use the flour from the
same
bag but all of ours were different
levels of soft the instant
was super hard the active dry was kind
of the mama bear of them it was like
kind of the in between the fresh was
like super soft so because we want to
have a little more control over our
dough
we wanted to use active dry so to wake
it up we're going to put it in
a liquid and the sugar and butter are
going to act as food for these to make
our blooming liquid
we're going to start with some warm milk
we're going to add a little bit of warm
water
and melted butter to that we're going to
add sugar sugar is going to be the main
thing that's going to give our yeast
some food to really quickly start to
work in goes our yeast
we're going to stir it to make sure the
granules can evenly dissolve
and be mixed in evenly with all those
ingredients so we're going to leave that
for about five minutes
and it should look something like this
if you don't see anything close to this
you should throw everything away and
start with some new yeast your yeast
might be old or dead
so once you've bloomed our yeast we're
gonna set it off to the side
and goes the flour and the salt and
we're going to super quickly incorporate
the salt into the flour
again so it doesn't like hit a huge
block of salt when the yeast goes in
we're going to add an egg to this dough
that's going to further enrich our dough
it's also going to give us a little bit
of color
a bit of extra flavor and a bit of add
it to our bloomed yeast mixture
and then just quickly as you can pour it
into the flour i'm going to use the same
knife
just to hydrate as much of the flour as
quickly as i can
so once i'm getting it to a roughly kind
of shaggy dough
i can pour it out of my bowl without
making too huge a mess
onto a clean floured surface and really
start to make this into a dough
this dough is definitely on the water
side so you want to keep a little bit of
bench flour and that just means
a little extra flour around to add to
your dough as you go to make it a little
bit easier to work with
and so that it's not too wet
the cool thing with bread is that wetter
is better unlike pastry which you want
to be on the dryer side
so it's pretty fun to work with it's
pretty easy to work with as well but
if it's really sticking to your hands or
to the surface all you need to do is add
a little bit more flour and it'll
be much easier to work with and
depending on like how old your flour is
how big your egg is i mean there's so
much that's going in here you're
probably gonna need more flour than you
think
before you go too far get all these
extra bits off your hands from when you
first start rolling because no matter
what like you're gonna have a little bit
of those scraggly bits on your hands
so get those off and start incorporating
those into your dough early so that you
don't have like big scraggly bits later
on again because you're going to be
kneading for a good 10 minutes or so
those will
pretty easily be incorporated into the
dough but if you wait too long then
you'll just have like a big chunk
so kneading this is one thing that i
think people tend to
under do almost always so if you're
doing this by hand
i promise you it's like almost
impossible to over knead if you are
using a stand mixer
it is possible and what will start to
happen it will kind of fall apart
it'll just turn almost like liquidy and
that means that you've just overworked
the gluten and you over needed it but by
hand
trust me you're probably underneath it
what i like to do is i like to roll the
dough on top of itself and then push it
out
rotate fold it over itself push again
rotate pull over itself and push so you
can just continue to do this i like to
work
kind of in a bit of a ball shape always
making kind of the shape of a roll and
once i'm getting the dough to a place
that i kind of like i'm actually going
to switch to this heart method it just
makes it a little bit more efficient
so you just roll it back and then by the
time you've come down towards you it's
in the shape of a cylinder almost
and then you roll the other way so
you're making sure that you're really
evenly
kneading out the dough and not totally
exhausting one of your arms
and to tell that you've needed enough a
really easy thing to do is to pull off a
piece of the dough
and make a little bit of a window pane
with it and stretch it out if it doesn't
tear
you can actually see those strands of
gluten that have developed and that
should give you
a pretty good indicator that your dough
is ready to rise or
you can push into the dough and if it
bounces back at you you've developed
enough gluten and the dough is ready to
sit once we're ready we're going to oil
a bowl
put our dough inside of it make sure
that's covered in the oil as well so it
doesn't stick
and then cover with cling film to rise
in a warm area
and then to get all of the dough and
flour and everything off the bench
these bench scrapers are amazing and
such an easy like cooks tool should
definitely get one
as this cling film kind of fogs up
that's actually all this gas being
released that we talked about that's the
yeast working
so all of that rising in that dough is
creating a little bit of like
condensation within the bowl
so this is actually a rise the proof is
going to happen
after it's doubled in size if you want a
slow rise you can put the dough in your
fridge whereas if leaving it out in a
warm place it'll happen a lot quicker
with active dry yeast
it should double in size in about an
hour take off the cling
and pop so we punch it pretty much just
because it's fun
but also because we're gonna turn out
the dough and even out all those bubbles
in the dough
so i'm gonna knead it again for a few
minutes and kind of even out the
different texture within the dough
and then we're gonna cut it into pieces
so if you want
super exact dough balls you should
definitely invest in a scale
and weigh them out another trick if you
want really even sized bread rolls
is to always work in halves so the
easiest thing for me is i just continue
to cut things in half so i have this big
piece
i'm going to cut this piece in half and
just continue to cut these pieces in
half
and for me it's easier to make them into
round balls again
um again just to make sure that i'm
being super you know precise with my cut
to get even sized bread rolls
so now that we have our dough divided
into its pieces it's time to shape them
into their cute little rolls
so before i even start shaping it i'm
going to start to knead the little
pieces
so you can do a few different things you
can knead it the same way that we were
talking about before
and press it into a little disc first
and then take the outer pieces and push
them into the center but what you're
really trying to do
when it's all said and done regardless
of whatever technique you use is you're
trying to make
the bottom of the piece that you're
rolling taut so what we really want is
to gather
all the outside pieces in the middle and
then make the top of it top so what i'm
doing here is i'm using my hands to kind
of
pinch from like the middle of the roll
to the very bottom
and when i do that i'm also rotating my
hands
so every time i'm doing that i'm
squeezing the bottom
and making sure that i'm making the top
taut
and making all the ugly pieces be on the
bottom so take your time with shaping
like you've gotten it this far
you know make sure that they're really
beautiful when it's all said and done
but this is also something that you can
definitely outsource i always get made
fun of a tasty because i'm always trying
to like give people jobs to do but
you know if you have a whole bunch of
people coming over this is definitely an
easy way
to get everyone involved and playing
with dough is very satisfying there's
just something about it that's very
like soothing and very like soulful in
some ways so there's no one who's gonna
say no
i mean it's so fun to do so once we're
happy with
all of our shaped dough i'm gonna place
them on a parchment-lined baking sheet
and you want them to be a little bit far
but not too far
because i really want these to touch a
little bit that's the dinner roll look
like you gotta have it
i know you're eager you've gotten these
all and they're perfect shapes but they
need to rise just a little bit more
so the first one was the rise and now
our rolls are going to proof we're gonna
cover it up with cling
and then let it sit for 30 minutes an
hour we want them to rise again we've
been a little bit like needy with the
dough you guys have had like too much
time together
so now the dough needs a little bit of
space uh before it'll really perform
and look how pillowy those are i mean
seriously like look how much they've
risen and they're now touching but not
too much
last thing so if you watched our pie
episode we tested a whole bunch of
different
washes to put on dough before it goes in
the oven and honestly egg is just super
easy and classic and gives you a really
great shiny brown
and for that dinner roll shine like you
need an egg wash
take your time like these are delicate
little babies at this point so if you
come in real hot with that brush and
just like really poke them
they will deflate a little bit now this
is totally optional but we are going to
top ours with a little bit of
sea salt mostly because i just could
never get enough salt
season high the higher you go it'll be a
more even
distribution if you season too close to
the roll it'll all kind of get in one
clump i'm sure you've
experienced that before chest at a few
different temperatures so bread ideally
does need a pretty high heat but these
are little baby rolls so we did have to
throw back the heat a little bit we
ended up with 3.75
wow and that gives us like the perfect
amount of brown
while cooking the rolls through freshly
baked bread
is just one of those things that i mean
the crumb on this the texture here
i mean you could sleep on this it's like
a pillow i mean look at that
it's got a great sweet savory flavor on
the inside
got the sesame seeds you can do garlic
butter you can do
i mean anything or you can do nothing
and just sop it up with some
gravy or butter or jam or it cannot be
overstated
how much this fourth utensil will
contribute to your next dinner party i'm
not eating anything else this holiday
season aside from bread rolls
make these bread rolls tag us in your
photos because i
need to know that the world believes in
bread rolls as much as we believe in
bread rolls
you